翻訳: Mitsumasa Mito
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さん
どうやったら面白い街が作れるのか
考えたり 試したりした事ってありますか
僕は日頃 建築デザイン事務所を
３人でやっています
建築という分野では 建物が建つ
敷地の周辺環境にも目を向け
建物を設計する必要があります
そういった周辺に対する興味から
業務とは別に
街に関わる活動を始めました
その活動について
お話しできればと思います
７年半前
僕は 地方の中堅都市である—
ここ浜松の街中に移り住みました
生活圏で言えばさらに小さく
自宅から半径約500mくらいの範囲です
正直言うと それ以外の地域では
地名を言われてもなんとなく
方角がわかるくらいで
距離感を未だに掴めていません
なので この半径500mの範囲を
街として捉え 活動しています
街にいると
「昔に比べて 浜松の街中は寂しくなった」
しばしばこういう意見を聞きます
皆さんはどう思いますか？
寂しい つまらない と思う方？
ありがとうございます
しかし こういった意見を聞くたびに
そうかな 結構面白い街じゃないかな
と思っています
確かに90年代前半までは
駅の周辺に たくさんの
大型商業施設があり
中心地では 通行人の肩が
ぶつかり合うほどで
お店の人もトイレに行くのを
我慢していたと聞きます
今では考えられない状況です
でも こういった商業的 経済的な
発展だけではない
面白さや価値が
街にはあるのではないでしょうか
街を作るためには何が必要でしょうか
すぐに思いつくのは 建物や道
といったハードウェアです
世界各地で 新しい場所 古い場所
形は異なりますが
どの都市も建物や道があることから考えると
ハードウェアが街を作るために
重要な要素だということは明らかです
僕の日頃の仕事も
そんな街のハードに関わる仕事です
街中では 小さな休憩ブースや
店舗や住居など その規模は様々ですが
手がけているプロジェクトは
約15にのぼります
今では 見学に来た方に
プロジェクトを紹介するときは
ちょっとした街中の散策のようになります
例えば
通常 建材ではない
帯状のブラインドカーテンを壁に用い
キッチンと倉庫の拡張を行った
お蕎麦屋さんでご飯を食べ
その後 昔オーナーさんが使っていた
木造のロフトの部材を
転用した美容室の休憩小屋や
同じビルの１階にある
積層ダンボールを什器として使った
眼鏡屋さんを案内します
また別のビルに移動すると
店主の働く姿がショーウィンドウとなる
アパレルショップや
店舗の光環境と
商品ディスプレイのために
間接光を使った陶器屋さんを
見て回ることができます
こういった街中のプロジェクトに
共通する特徴の一つは
少し古い建物に対して
材料や建物の特性を考慮しながら利用し
新しい空間を生み出すことです
皆さんもリノベーションという言葉を
ご存知かと思いますが
近年ではこういった古い建物が
味があるものとして見直されています
浜松の街中の建物も
現在では出来ないような
手仕事の美しさや
個人のお店として使うのに
ちょうどいい規模感など
ハードとして多くの美点があります
そして 紹介ツアーを終えて
参加者に感想をうかがうと
オーナーさんの空間の使い方や
僕たちとオーナーさんの関係性の近さが
とても良かったと言っていただけます
僕たちの作品自体を褒めていただいて
いるのかなっていう気はしますけど
ポジティブに解釈すると
僕たちが作ったハードウェアが
物や人の関係を活き活きさせていると
言っていただいているんだと思っています
僕の解釈はさておき
これらの感想が示していることは
使い方はとても重要だということです
どんなに良い建築
つまりハードウェアも
使う人がいなければ
廃墟になってしまいます
反対に 活き活きとした使い方を
されることで
これまで見向きもされなかったような
建物や場所が
実はとても面白いものだ ということに
気付くことさえあります
そこで 街の使い方を考える
ということをテーマに活動しています
活動を通して
街に関わっている人は二つの立場を
持っていると感じています
一つ目は 使い手
プレイヤーとしての立場です
もう一つは 使い手を応援する
サポーターとしての立場です
僕の活動も同様に
二つの立場を持っています
ここで そのそれぞれの立場で行った
プロジェクトを２つご紹介したいと思います
まずはプレイヤーとしての活動です
これは植野聡子さんと共同で企画した
『パーキング』というプロジェクトです
このプロジェクトでは街中の
平面駐車場に着目しています
全国の地方都市で
市街地の建物が取り壊されると
その多くの土地が駐車場となります
浜松の街中も例外ではありません
駐車場自体 街の入口となる
必要なインフラなんですが
駐車されていない時は 街にとって
空き地のような存在になってしまっています
この『パーキング』というプロジェクトでは
その使われていない時間を利用して
ピクニックしてしまおうという試みです
知人のお花屋さんに
お花の移動販売をしてもらいながら
ワークショップや
アーティストのトークイベントを企画して
駐車場でのんびり過ごします
街のもったいないと思われる場所を
活き活きとした場所に変換する実験です
次にサポーターとしての活動です
これは万年橋パークビルという
立体駐車場の最上階部分です
年間を通して稼働率が低かったこの空間を
フリースペースのような形で使いたい
とお話をいただいて 僕が運営しています
当初は 元は駐車場ですし
何ができるんだろう という感じでした
ただ 体育館やホールといった
特定の目的でしか利用できない場所ではなく
利用者さんが使い方を見出していける
ような場所がいいと思って
運営は最低限に
日程の調整だけに留めました
利用料金もありません
無料なので 急にいろんなことが起こっても
対処に困ると思って
告知をやめて
商店街の関係者と
知人だけに伝えて使っていました
１年ぐらい経つと
徐々に人から人へと伝わったのか
知らない人からも
連絡が来るようになりました
今では
近隣の商店主や学生が
遊ぶために利用したり
講演会や
イラストレーターの展覧会
音楽イベントや
マルシェなど
多種多様な使われ方がされています
いろんなことが起こるようになって
さすがに 内容によっては有料としましたが
運営の仕方は今も大きくは変わっていません
これらの主催の方々は 準備はもちろん
必要があれば 近隣への挨拶や
イベントが重なった時の場所の調整などを
当人同士でやっていただいています
管理し過ぎずに
使いたいと言っていただいた方を
できるだけ応援するっていうのは
利用者さんにとっても
実は運営にとっても
手間がかかりますし
時には問題が起こります
それでも 利用される方が
運営に関わることによって
皆さんきっと自分たちの場所だと
思っていただいていると思っています
こんなことが起こるとは
最初に相談をくださった
パークビルの社長さんは
想像と違った と思っていると思います
でも
僕が運営を託されて以降
やり方を変えてとは言われていないので
きっと 駐車場の売り上げが伸びて
それに貢献していると 判断して
いただいているのだと思っています
とても良い社長さんです
このように
街の使い方を考えるということは
建物をハードウェアとすると
ソフトウェアを考えることと言えます
新たな もしくは街にとって必要な
ソフトウェアを作ることで
面白いことをやる人が集まり
新たな人と人の関係を生んでいます
この両輪が面白い街をつくっていくために
とても重要だと思っています
僕が最初に 浜松の街を
結構面白い街じゃないかなと言った理由は
このハードウェアとソフトウェアが
うまく影響しあって
経済的な価値だけではない価値が
街に生まれていて
しかも そのいい状態が自発的に
継続されていると思っているからです
言い方を変えると
今 街にあるものの良さを発見しながら
これまでにない試みで活用できる場所
そしてそれらを応援する土壌がある
それが浜松の街 ということです
こう考えると この良いサイクルは
浜松だけではなく ほかの街でも
作ることができるかもしれません
なので浜松は この街の価値を
育てていくことでさらに面白い街へと
成長できるのではないかと思っています
もちろん これは僕一人だけで
できることではありません
今 浜松の街に住んでいる人—
訪れる人がこの街の良さに触れて
価値観が共有されることで
広がっていくことだと思っています
僕が浜松に来た当時に比べて
すでに面白くなっています
皆さん 最近浜松の街中に
遊びに来たことってありますか？
面白くなっていく街を
ぜひ覗きに来てください
（ 拍手 ）